el consejo constitucional francés da luz
verde al pase sanitario por lo que a
partir del 9 de agosto para entrar en
bares restaurantes y terrazas será
necesario presentar un certificado de
vacunación de recuperación de la
enfermedad o un test negativo un
pasaporte que ya se exige desde el 21 de
julio en lugares culturales y de ocio
algunos propietarios ya han declarado su
oposición a la medida un grupo de
restauradores de la región de bretaña ha
emitido un comunicado que ha sido
replicado en la prensa francesa
somos lugares abiertos a todos sin
distinción somos cafés no clubes
privados somos lugares de encuentro
donde la diferencia y la mezcla son una
riqueza el pase sanitario también será
necesario para visitar las residencias
de mayores y para entrar al hospital con
dolencias consideradas no urgentes una
medida que la federación hospitalaria
francesa estima que costará 60 millones
de euros mensuales que podrían
invertirse en reforzar los recursos de
los centros públicos por otro lado la
ley también obliga al personal
sociosanitario entre otros sectores
profesionales a vacunarse sin embargo el
consejo consideró que era
inconstitucional
despedir a un trabajador de la salud con
un contrato a corto plazo que rechace la
vacuna obligatoria la norma ha desatado
convocatorias de huelga por parte de
sindicatos como la cgt pero el gobierno
de momento no piensa renunciar a ella
evitó que hay un par de sindicatos que
llamaron a la huelga se lo digo viene un
tiempo en que estas personas no tendrán
ocasión de hacer huelga porque por
definición la obligación de vacunarse se
aplicará finalmente el tribunal
dictaminó que la imposición de diez días
de aislamiento para los enfermos de kobe
19 es anticonstitucional ya que supone
una privación de libertad que no está
basada en la decisión individualizada de
la autoridad judicial o administrativa
el veredicto del consejo es la última
etapa para la entrada en vigor de la
legislación que ha sido abrazada por
unos y rechazada por otros en las calles
de fran